tout le monde aime ça va commencer
[Musique]
tous
[Applaudissements]
c'est justement ce sens la gravière
d'haragama bras
oui c'est une surprise pour toi
le fameux jeu dont tu m'avais parlé j'ai
d'accord tu sais c'est un jeu vous le
troisième quart de ce côté comme cela
oui on la choisit de l'autre côté à
l'anti maman celle que tu vois ce que tu
veux à tanger 'phishing' pixon de
vieillevigne d'accord des écoutes tu
l'as dans le jeu et alors là nous allons
essayer quelque chose de transmission
regarde je vais simplement dire
abracadabra et alors là de ce côté mais
quatre normales mais de l'autre côté les
cartes sont blanches et entièrement
blanche et métiers et chacune et oui
c'est la seule chaigneau qui si on
regarde bien on arrive à les reconnaître
même s'ils paraissent plonge voilà le
fallait car au 1/8 de coeur je veux 3 2
trèfles jeu froide un petit peu sur la
carte et de l'autre côté elle devient
blanche également tu vois mais si
maintenant alors je refais un petit
geste magique abracadabra propre les
cartes qui sont blanches de ce côté de
vienne blanche de l'autre côté
entièrement blanche et la carte aussi
devenues blanches des deux côtés pour
s'indigner picard et oui il a disparu
mais ce que tu dois savoir ce qu il
suffit d pape et l'a peut-être en la
cherchant la rue au nom on a pas de
changement j'irai de l'autre côté
peut-être non plus alors où sont les
points à la traîne en longueur
ballard m'écoute regarde ça tu as tout
avaler
alala alors là vraiment écoute garder
tout ça car pas la marque ocz est pas
très gentil c'est pas très gentil si on
touche là au moins 1400 branche dont
j'ai une autre idée je garde des points
et je vais maintenant essayer de faire
un deux trois tous les torts et
apparaissent comme au départ et draka la
voie pour le 5 de piquer réapparaissez
et de l'autre côté une carte 5 de pique
ainsi que toutes les autres cas qui sont
rien par an mais j'ai eu chaud
qu'est ce qui se passe en avions bien
drôle d'aller au lit gras et chez moi
qui suis fâché maintenir à bord est
complètement effacée tu ne peux même pas
juger de la date regarde mon calendrier
magique qu'elle est nouveau c'est très
joli que le voir s'en sont des cas qui
paraissent tous voir par exemple ici un
8-2 que la fédé regarde y'a je fais
juste un geste sur la table et ça
devient 1979 demain gérard - gmac a
annon cé ça hein c'est vrai et oui 1979
voilà je note ira à
[Musique]
un quidam
à la con
[Musique]
la sec
il veut
[Musique]
m
daf maintenant
com
ap
[Musique]
est
et oui et oui mais
[Musique]
enjoy
attends fautes en coup dur aujourd'hui
sapin nom il s'appelle will we bought en
bout d'une petite braille dans des
moules tout ça en poupe
sappi fine vers son fils kadhafi
dépenser mais non
abdou
willie walsh étant que tu aimes était
dans un état qui vont mouiller bouillie
est bordé de nouilles une bouille
[Musique]
mais non poutine attendus ou alimenter
ou d'innover et pourtant besoin d'eux on
touille oui mais non encore 8 août et le
dépôt de plainte est en cours en irlande
giuly au bruit mais vous des 2 attendus
bien son rôle on fermait à vous dans une
boutique s'appelle noël
[Musique]
oh
gérard oui on joue avec des cartes
si tu veux d'accord je tiens regarde une
carte noire pourrait voler trajet soit
aussi aussi vous tous les enfants prenez
une carte rouge
c'est le 9 de carreau et une autre carte
noire d'accord avec toi dire quoique
maintenant up
abracadabra terminé je n'ai plus que
maintenant deux cars poiret la carte
rouge un disparu et si j'étale le jeu il
ya une carte qui se trouve à l'envers
c'est bien notre 9 de carreau qui était
perdu
alors si je vois difficile à j'ai même
honte de vous donner une explication
en vérité l'une des cartes est truqué
elle est constituée par deux cartes 1 9
de carreau double de l'autre qui connaît
par du ruban adhésif ou même avec de la
colle mais ce sera plus serré comme cela
et cette carte est coupée un petit peu
elle est coupée dans le bout pour que
l'on puisse ensuite montré les trois
quarts de la façon suivante une première
noire on lâche la rouge bien total puis
la noire ensuite ils ont peint sur le
côté évidemment la carte rouge reste
derrière l'autre à laquelle elle est
collée et on est tranquille ensuite pour
pouvoir étaler le jeu et montrer la
deuxième carte rouge c'est que trois
points
mais stéphane me présente autrement un
monte au musée j'ai une cheminée un
panda un père noël et un sapin je
connais
ma cheminée pas d'un bon ça tue le père
noël ou ce qu'ils pensent et alberto
c'est pas toi qui leur est presque par
hasard
moi c'est pas toi moi oui tu peux mais
oui là dans ta poche c'est pas vrai
c'est regarde regarde
qu'est-ce qu'ils aient peur alors
vraiment il exagère mais pour la peine
on va jouer un bonbon avec toi d'accord
atteint correcteurs avec trois cartes
c'est un petit jeu très amusant sur deux
cartes noir et une carte au jeu teulé
montre bien je ne pourra pas dire que tu
triches et de noir une rouge la rouge
est là ici c'est une noire une autre
noire ou et la rouge au mieux bravo tu
as gagné un bonbon alors maintenant on
peut jouer une bûche un avatar de narita
bûche de noël
regarde bien la rouge est toujours là
ici nous avons une bande noire et
maintenant où est la rouge
j'ai gagné c'est au milieu et bien non
non non non non non tu n'as pas besoin
de toute façon qu'ils ne pourraient pas
gagner parce qu'en vérité il n'y a plus
du tout de rouge regarde lassitude voire
une deuxième mort avec la secte une
troisième mois mais si je veux te faire
gagner je souffle sur les cas en disant
abracadabra et j'ai ici une rouge une
des zones rouges et une troisième rouge
et pourtant les trois cartes sur normal
de noir une moule
tu vois tu as perdu tu as vu ce qu on
dit donc est il
[Musique]
oh
on
[Musique]
non
pour
[Musique]
man
oh
alors tu vois moustaches barbes
maintenant la perruque on dirait
vraiment un vrai père noël tu vois la
capuche
ça va ah oui c'est fort très bien quand
tu peux t'asseoir repose toi tu peux
même dormir un peu toute façon je
reviens tout de suite je vais voir si
elle dort vraiment regarde une cheminée
qui dit cheminée il y voit jouer
[Musique]
belote perdre comme ça ni vu ni connu à
la superbe très bien voilà
voilà six mois
tu es le de mal nous ne savons pas si
c'est toi qui l'a le nom se glisser
dedans et la braguette le ternois et là
le fait
e
ha ha dont on les a surpris un vous
vouliez volume les jouets des enfants
boué et bien pour la peine vous serez
punis et vous ne recevrez vos jouets que
dans quinze jours voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'arraché toi
[Musique]